smith plastic surgery the sponsors of
this next segment have you cut they have
you covered if you're ready to
rejuvenate your body or your face or
both whatever you prefer they can do it
all we spoke to one of their doctors to
learn more
i'm dr malcolm paul a clinical professor
of surgery university california i
joined the smith plastic surgery clinic
a couple of months ago because i've
moved to las vegas and
i really wanted to join a very busy and
multi-focused group
dr smith's clinic here encompasses all
of plastic surgery on the aesthetic side
which includes you know face neck body
contouring eyelid surgery
and we have a complete med spot part of
it we also have a unique
possession of a hyperbaric chamber which
improves healing after surgery
and we have frequently put patients in
there after facial surgery just to
improve the healing so my area of
expertise is really in doing a lot of
neck lifts and most patients come in
first because they see the neck aging
so-called turkey gobblers sort of neck
and especially in climates like this
where you see your neck first because of
low clothing
women come in men as well it's their
eyelids and it's your neck
and then of course to move into other
areas but i spent the last 10 years
really concentrating on making the neck
look like it was when you were a
teenager or in your 20s so rolling back
the clock 15 years at least along with
some deep plane lift techniques on the
central part of the face
i have a procedure i actually really
worked on over the past several years to
go through the lower eyelid and raise
the cheek back up to where it was when
you were younger to shorten the distance
between your lashes and your cheek which
if you look in the mirror and bring this
up you can actually do the same thing in
your live back it's called the mirror
face up if you put your head back about
45 degrees and put a mirror above your
head and look at it that's the result of
the surgery where if you're sitting
straight this way or even worse leaning
forward everything falls forward so the
way you simulate the results of a
facelift cheek lift a brow lift uh is to
lie
lie back uh at least 45 50 or 60 degrees
like so with a mirror above you exactly
what the end point would be with the
surgery that we're planning so that's
been exciting i'm doing a lot of cases
here we got busy almost as soon as i
joined i have a lot of publications i've
edited textbooks
i teach in several countries i just got
back i did a series of cases of teaching
a young plastic surgeon in ireland have
a license in bahrain in ireland in the
united kingdom california and nevada so
i'm excited to join the group it's a
terrific group
high level surgery wonderful anesthesia
very safe we have a terrific team of
personnel
pas and so forth the med spa has
everything possible to rejuvenate the
skin from the outside
tighten the skin with the serious
devices that we have and so when you
combine what we do in the inside with
what they do on the outside you get the
best results so one to one equals like
four or five not not just two so that's
where we are
thank you to smith plastic surgery for
sponsoring that segment for more call
702-838-2455
or just visit smithsurgery.com